how was the how was the experience
with dave uh and and what you guys built
together at the very beginning of kovid
life-changing it was amazing like all
the photos and stuff that were coming
out there
life
changing bro yeah it made me say
hollywood is overrated
[ __ ]
the business i i i mean
damn man it was like
i got in touch with nature
uh we you've really realized during the
pandemic
things that you appreciate what's really
important simple shit's important and we
take so many things for granted like
when a pandemic was going down it used
to [ __ ] me up to ride past a playground
and not see kids playing
simple [ __ ] like simple [ __ ] is like i
usually take my son
to the park
that's closed down
restaurants close down just simple [ __ ]
that you took for granted
you it made you appreciate it more and
then when i was out there was cornfields
like this life is simple you don't need
a lot
you don't you don't need a lot you don't
need to fancy [ __ ] you don't need to
start with the cars you need to be
around good people
they have positive energy that you can
build with create with and enjoy each
other
that's what we did
that summer
to this day people that came out and had
that experience they were like even when
the world opened back up where you could
start doing stuff people's like this i
want to go back to summer camp
because
we created a community of creatives
we would [ __ ]
party together cook together
and i know this is crazy [ __ ] we i was i
became the river ninja the river ninja
river ninja i got i got excited about
kayaking and canoeing
we went one day it was the most peaceful
[ __ ] i've ever experienced you cannot
imagine going down the [ __ ] mad river
with [ __ ] 40 canoes kayaks and uh 30
of them black people
had never been on the water before we
played pop smoke music and [ __ ] like
that we blew that goddamn river up
but it was a connection how rapid is it
this is like a cause a zero it wasn't
nowhere it was like they called it don't
disrespect me you had to ask a real
river question
rapid the only one i know one person
would ask what course was it was it a
three or was it
he was like if you happen to fall over
just stand up
that's how it was but it was a piece and
then you you
you realize that
like you could because at that time we
made hollywood
we were doing stuff nobody was doing we
were in ahead of uh rapid testing dave
got money so he found some kind of way
found a
a a pcr machine that with 20 minutes
results
wow he was one of the first people
or organizations or anything that
created a bubble
yeah
it was for the nba for everything he
created bubble he told me yo daniel i
want you [ __ ] come out here and
chill with me but i got to get you
[ __ ] here corona free
right
right like corona free this [ __ ]
everybody anybody you saw in those
photos yeah was flown in
on a pj
wow
yeah
everybody
that you saw in those photos
he flew in
on jets like it was like
it was like this okay what time does the
la jet come in
what time does it what time does a new
york jet to dc he went above and beyond
to for our safety and basically just to
get his friends together to have a good
time
how long would you guys stay out there
i stayed the entire summer wow i'll tell
you the time it was the best thing
nothing else was
open it was the best [ __ ] for us to be
able to have a bubble and that's what
made it so much special we were doing
everything when everybody was doing
nothing right you know and and like
nobody was getting paid we didn't have a
problem i was like this we're staying
like we locked down all the airbnbs out
there to hotel rooms and [ __ ] but when i
tell you
for your
mind your mental it was the best thing i
saw
saggit
get a new life
out there
i sort of look in his eyes of like oh my
god i started rebirth of his stand-up
career
i saw [ __ ] um
uh what's the white dude daily show
[ __ ] um jon stewart jon stewart
i saw him
not performing for months come out there
like oh my god
like take a test like i can hug you
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah i saw
people creative people that didn't have
an outlet i saw darius rucker come out
there i'm in the back of a goddamn
pickup truck smoking a joint with him
singing the songs that he don't ever
want to hear
i'm over there like this and when the
sun comes out
i'm seeing during his record like
i haven't played it so long we go to
dave's little like speak easy spot
and he's like i want to play so bad i
went to one of my friends i'm like
that's in the music [ __ ] i was like i
need a guitar you got a guitar yeah but
it's in yellow springs i'm like
[ __ ] we in yellow springs
go get it
darius rucker wants to [ __ ] play
he goes get it he puts on the side then
he goes start talking these [ __ ]
again i was like we need to get this
[ __ ] tuned right darius [ __ ] in the
back
and come up and i bring them in
and the [ __ ] start playing
right it's a small group of people
and
there's some people talking in the
background
dave's on dave had a couple of drinks
he's on the [ __ ] mic i snatched the
mic from dave i said listen [ __ ]
i don't know any of you [ __ ]
that have ever sold 25 million of
anything
i was like we are in the presence of a
[ __ ] legend whatever you think about
them i said if you think your
conversation is bigger than jerry's
record giving us a little private
concert take that [ __ ] outside
yeah right some real [ __ ] yeah you know
you know how many white [ __ ] i [ __ ]
off of
hold my hand i mean it's gotta be a lot
a lot but that was my intro song and
people used to be engaged right and i
used to come out there when we were
doing all right that was my intro song
so when we went out
to yellow springs we were doing the
shows with dave i just brought the song
back
so that's my song and everybody's like
yeah i wanna honey
and a couple of guys like yo man
it would be so [ __ ] crazy man if you
got darius rucker right here i'm like
this i can't do that just so what
happened at the time kate quickly good
friend of mine yep she was dating them
and i invited her out because one thing
about the uh the cornfield shows was
that anybody i was close to
i would encourage them to come out there
just to get away from the nonsense yeah
just to feel the vibe i was like oh you
got to experience this so i invited her
out she was like yeah maybe i'll bring
my boyfriend
i was like who's your boyfriend she was
like i was like
yeah i was like i turned gates and i was
like
i want to run with you
yo right and i
said to her i was like
i said um i said and i hold my hand i
was saying the lyrics some of his lyrics
to her she thought i was hitting on her
she didn't know that i was singing the
lyrics i was like yesterday she was like
daniel i'm seeing somebody already
right so
she invited
and i'm geeking bro i was darry's record
in the late 90s jerry's work
i'm geeking i meet him
right i'm like oh [ __ ]
he's just so humble and cool we're in
the green room so
before
now he's like a
clean guy
country dude probably never heard him
curse or anything yeah
so he's going to get his seat
and i'm nervous going back to say i was
nervous to perform sure because i know
i'm going to use his song as my intro so
he's leaving agreement to go get his
seat and he says this is what he says to
me he said [ __ ] you better be funny
[Laughter]
i was like
just called me the anywhere
i feel like i was in a chapel sketch i
was like i felt validated
the worst thing to tell a community is
be funny because now you get the
pressure yeah and you panic yeah so i go
on stage
and i'm i'm doing my my intro walk on
music is
yesterday i'm gonna man whatever and
i'll get called and responsible to the
audience that's just my thing i do the
show now i'm still want to make an
impression i was like maybe jerry's
record didn't feel me
so i'm trying to say dj yeah i play that
[ __ ] again y'all [ __ ] and i'm
trying to get people to sing i was like
it's not a [ __ ] in here
not no [ __ ] here know the words in this
song now one [ __ ] know the words
this song
and all of a sudden
from the back
this [ __ ] has a mic
dirty's record i'm telling trying to
encourage the audience to sing it and
this [ __ ] comes up
behind me yesterday
i saw you yo the [ __ ]
cornfields went [ __ ]
i was like
i wanted we was going back and forth one
of the best moments and and i'm telling
you after that i told everybody i was
like i'm the [ __ ]
no i'm telling you i was like this i'm
the [ __ ] why do you say that because of
this [ __ ] moment
a moment that everybody dreamt of
actually happened
he was the coolest [ __ ] we get
in the back of a pickup truck that's
some white boy country [ __ ] yeah it
really is pickup truck i didn't give a
[ __ ] about the bumps
and we had the time
of our life and that's what
the whole summer camp
feeling was yeah it was unity
i became the river ninja you did i came
up with a phrase son i said [ __ ]
hollywood i'm going from the streets to
the creeks i love that from the hoods to
the woods love that from [ __ ] to oars
that's great from adidas to tivas wow do
you know how much money i save river
[ __ ] don't cost a lot nothing no i
took three river [ __ ] shopping
at marshalls
listen i spent 348.92
i still got a receipt to prove it
i had three grocery shopping carts full
of [ __ ]
not like i mean grocery carts right big
the ones that need a wheel alignment
i could have [ __ ] had a menage a
choir with all these [ __ ] they all
had dresses they had [ __ ] candles
wild candles yeah cause you can't go to
marshall like getting a candle right
right they had some type of salt grinder
they're never gonna use
348.92 i still have the receipt for it i
was bawling out there buckeye [ __ ]
for the win
yo
[ __ ] got coupons
they save money yeah they don't want to
spend money on a lot of [ __ ] they'd be
like this i wish i would pay 30 for a
dress right
i could go down there with this coupon i
could get that same michael kors dress
for 19.99 buckeye [ __ ] for the win
yeah a guy can save a lot of money
dating a woman who who appreciates a
value yeah another thing i liked about
this people say what did you like about
being in ohio the most
i
was
a sex symbol
yo
i though [ __ ] was calling me fine
really yes look at this face yeah this
face looks like it needs something to
get [ __ ] with
like a gun
a sense of humor a lot of money a very
big dick this is not a face that could
get [ __ ] or face alone the watch helps
yeah what the blingy bling oh god i can
[ __ ] every part of bethel
a family
[Laughter]
yo man i just i don't know i just i fell
in love with ohio man this summer it
took a summer and i fell in love with it
is there is there
is there is there any ways to recreate
what happened that summer or is it great
great question thank you
we've had
experience after that
the reason why you could never recreate
that summer is because
it's the state of the world and what
made it so special
is that we were doing it at a time when
nobody was doing anything
that's what that's what that's the time
capsule yeah yeah we can do like they we
we do it like annually now it's never
going to feel the same as everything's
closed you're open yeah pushing it
trying to be normal it's never going to
be that and then when i look back when i
was like this
like we was like yeah we want to go back
to the river yeah we could go back to
the river but in that situation when the
world was shut down to do something
that's what made it really special and
like you said with nobody making money
it would have to be a scenario where
people aren't making money anyway like
now that everybody's got gigs and
everything nobody had to give up money
to go exactly right that's gonna be a
tough thing now you did like you said to
your point
it's like
oh yeah but i was gonna make 30 racks
here
but do i want to go in the river right
the river's going to be kind of empty
but with memorial day weekend what i'm
going to start doing it's like i'm going
to still do my river runs
you know i'm going to open it up to the
public because that's everybody that
came here everybody said yo i want to go
to the river i want to go to the river
stewart chris rock
all uh louis ck i want to keep
that tradition going but as far as the
shows i don't know
if that'll happen anymore but i want to
hit the river it's just like so calm and
so peaceful
well the donnell rowling show is
available on all podcast platforms as
well as on don l rawlings youtube you
can see him tonight through sunday
caroline's on broadway and then he's
touring all over the place california
miami philly detroit
donnellrollings.com is the place to be
you can follow him on twitter and every
instagram everywhere at donell rawlings
we appreciate you man i appreciate i i
don't get excited about a lot of
interviews but our history and [ __ ] i
was like yeah i think this maybe maybe i
can't maybe this is like my third time i
want to say it was three or four i i
you've been here before and definitely
on the old on a show but it's been a few
not enough times though
but i got excited no homo pause you're
gonna say that i understand yeah yeah i
knew i was gonna come up here and chat
up with you appreciate you love you guys
yeah awesome man seeing you buddy we'll
talk to you soon